in fact i think somewhere months ago i
said i thought i was betting that fauci
is actually excellent at his job um it
just isn't
well he's been at something um but you
know we
well let's put it this way there's an
interesting discussion beginning to
bubble up behind the scenes and a lot of
these interesting discussions happen
amongst people who have crossed the
rubicon and are in the hinterlands
um months before they show up in public
so you know mass formation showed up in
the malone podcast on joe rogan but we
had been talking about mass formation
for quite some time uh the matthias
desmond model and you and i had been
talking about the
impression that we had that there was
clearly some kind of emergent psychosis
overtaking the world right we saw it and
we named it that before we knew what
mass formation psychosis even was so i
like desmond's formulation but
nonetheless the point is there's a long
discussion of what really matters that
shows up before the public suddenly
becomes aware that there's a discussion
at all and so the discussion i want to
reference now there's a discussion
beginning to happen
about
whether
bodily autonomy is really even the point
right some of us i've been very careful
not to invoke bodily autonomy because as
i frequently say there are scenarios in
which you can imagine that mandates
would be justified and i don't want to
say anything that suggests that the very
fact of mandates are invalid however
the question you know so people will
maybe have seen me say or tweet
not these vaccines
not these public health authorities not
this pathogen right mandates fails on
three separate grounds here these
vaccines aren't effective enough or safe
enough the pathogen isn't dangerous
enough universally enough
and the public health authorities are
not free of corruption enough that we
could justify mandates but
right not even close here's where i
think this is headed though
i believe it is conceivable
that you could have
a governmental structure good enough to
be entrusted with the question of
mandates in a sufficiently serious
situation
i don't believe that government has ever
existed i believe we have to leave it
open as a theoretical possibility that
it is not a fact of history that we've
had such governments and that we do or
don't have one now we have a terrible
instantiation but none of the
governments none of the human
architected governmental structures has
been up to that challenge which means
that at least we need we need a new
structure then because the existing
structures can't bring the best of
humanity out of us and give us the
government that maybe we deserve but
certainly we want right and i completely
agree we need to figure out what that
structure is as you and i argue in our
book it's not a structure that we can
blueprint nobody on earth knows how to
blueprint it but we could navigate to it
we could prototype our way to it we
could evolve our way to it but in the
present stuck with the governmental
structures that we have the argument
would be
these governmental structures are not up
to the challenge of mandating and
overriding bodily autonomy they are not
up to that challenge and in light of the
fact that they are not up to that
challenge and nothing could be done to
them that would make them up to that
challenge they are allowed one tool and
one tool only and that tool is
persuasion
right if they want us to take their
remedy because it is the right remedy
and because it is better than the others
and because that's how we will protect
each other they're one tool
is to convince us
and they have completely failed to
convince us why
because the tools they have presented us
are completely crappy because their
corruption is so obvious and because we
can detect that what they are doing is
taking any counter-argument and doing
their best to silence it to stigmatize
it to shunt it off the side of the map
right so we know we're not having a fair
conversation about what the best path
forward is we can all see that right
that's why people are being thrown off
twitter and youtube right that's what
this is about it is about creating the
false impression that their argument is
actually robust when it could not
possibly be more feeble and i don't know
i'm sick of it and we are now faced with
omicron and we are
really left with the question of whether
or not the test did they pass the test
so well with respect to previous
variants that we are still listening to
their advice with respect to this one
even though this one is so different and
their advice hasn't changed doesn't that
tell you this isn't about us
this is about
their
i don't know i guess business interests
or whatever it is but it's certainly not
about us because the fact is the the
disease is so different the advice would
certainly have changed if this was any
sort of rational process and yet it
doesn't in fact what they do is they
pretend they they what's the
retcon they retcon things retcon
retroactive continuity where they tell
us oh
it was always the case that the vaccines
were designed to prevent serious disease
they were never designed to prevent
transmission of the disease so the fact
that they don't prevent you from
contracting or transmitting the disease
and they don't reduce viral loads oh
that was all expected it's all part of
the design well [ __ ]
right we all heard them tell us that it
was about control
i'm reminded as you talk
um you know just as maybe there are
maybe many of them are actually doing
their jobs very very well and we just
don't know what their jobs are
um
[Music]
maybe the public health policy is very
much doing what it's supposed to do and
we have just been misled by its
packaging
a point you have made in different forms
in in many ways that because it has the
words public health in it we assume that
it's about public health but that's our
bad for being so gullible
and i'm reminded of the thinking of the
great john taylor gato recently deceased
who was an extraordinary educator and
who wrote among other things
weapons of mass instruction
and dumbing us down
and i've talked about his work um before
on this podcast but in one of his books
he goes through a history of compulsory
schooling which if memory serves sort of
emerges from
german a german model in the late 19th
century which the americans um
import and it's it's basically like the
robber barons
the you know the the the rich tycoons of
the turn of the 19th to 20th century
who need
mindless workers
to do the work of the new industrialized
world post-industrial revolution that
explains the format of schools
that schooling is not about creating
well-informed citizens who can make
decisions for themselves it is precisely
about creating cogs that is in fact the
point
and this this feels a bit like that you
say school you say education you imagine
sweet children bursting out of a
classroom into recess and then going
back into
into the classroom to learn the good
things that they need to learn and maybe
that was never the point at all
and maybe the point of public health
policy has not been at least for this
for this little pandemic of ours the
entire world has been dragged through
for almost two years now has never the
public health response has never been
about public health but about but about
compliance but about seeing how far you
can push a population
and
maybe as a practice run
i don't know but they do know a whole
lot about how all of us will behave now
they know who will tend to be compliant
they know who will carry water for them
they know who will ramp up their fears
because it feels good because they can
get other people to do things based on
their fears
there's a whole lot of knowledge now
about what different quadrants of
society and what different individuals
will do and will not do
and that is
dangerous you know we have been
experiencing the death of privacy in
many forms by a thousand cuts for
decades now but this feels like
you know maybe the final blow
but
i don't even i don't know how to phrase
this so that it will
be hearable
we
i know that natural rights is a fraught
concept but the thing is
we are human beings we get one life
in this life
halfway through for us or more
suddenly a virus that appears to be the
product of really bad decision making
emerges out of a lab in china
that really bad decision making had
anthony fauci as a prominent
he was
at least an architect of the offshoring
of the work that seems to have caused
this pandemic
and yet he is also
somehow in a prominent position where he
gets to tell you and me you having
apparently contracted a descendant of
the virus that he stupidly had
engineered
somehow he gets to tell you and me how
we are to manage the consequences of
this you and i are phd's in evolutionary
biology
we are capable of looking at this and
saying i don't think that solution
you've handed me is any good at all and
here's why
i am also capable as you are capable of
saying you know what
i've talked to dr corey i've heard what
he has to say i've heard him revise his
understanding of things in light of new
evidence we've talked to dr mccullough
france and light of what and in light of
new variants
right the people who are thinking on
their feet are also recognizing that no
matter how much information they had
last month what is happening now may be
different because the informa it's not
just that the information is new to them
but what is true is actually changing
this is also true right and you know
we've heard from dr malone himself
vaccinated right
the inventor of the technology that
underlies these vaccines we've heard him
talk about the hazard of of these things
to us how is it that we attempting to
act responsibly and in the interests of
ourselves and of our family are not
entitled to make those calls
how can it be it just seems to me
so
such an inversion of decency that
anthony fauci has more say over what we
are allowed to think and not think do
and not do than we do when anthony fauci
has demonstrated at best incompetence he
is a key player in the escape of this
virus into the world the creation of it
and the escape and all of that ought to
have him absolutely silenced in this
conversation responsible people who have
proven that they can handle the
complexities ought to be in a position
of responsibility it's some kind of
kafka s nightmare where anthony fauci
has all of the say over what we get to
do
i mean look
somehow it would appear that you
actually have contracted a virus that
seems to have been engineered downstream
of a fouchy offshoring grant through uh
through
eco health alliance right that's an
amazing fact
right that error in judgment has reached
out and touched you at the cellular
level right frankly
as we have talked about
i
i will be glad to have had it and in
fact it's been so trivial by and large
um that it was never really that much of
a big deal i am angry at the timing in
part because this place that we were
going to be going was florida which
we've spent almost no time at all
but by all accounts uh
one of our son's friends spent the
winter break in florida and came back
saying
came back to portland oregon saying it
feels so normal there
it feels so
normal and uh we've been in texas
recently enough to say that that's
largely the case there too we're just in
austin but um
you know there a lot of the country
doesn't feel quite so crazy so somehow
some some number of
other political authorities not public
health authorities perhaps are saying uh
to the talking head uh that fills the
screens if you turn it on uh no actually
not not your choice
and um you know this
we have been hearing too uh from many
conservatives in the last few months
saying this is our objection
to
uh liberal forms of government because
no government
will be good enough like this this is in
fact uh the the response that that we're
getting from
from honest wonderful conservatives who
say now now you see nice well and you
know i to the extent that that is their
point it is absolutely right and i would
just
add it's not like
governments don't have the right to make
policy but the point is the tool by
which they should get there
is persuasion they have to persuade us
that this is actually the right path and
they mandating it is obscene in light of
where this virus came from and in light
of what they've done to both the
discussion and to the tools available to
you and your doctor in order to deal
with the condition
and our point would be
you know to your point earlier they need
we need to invent something by which the
structures are in place to allow people
to be their best self so that we can
have a governance structure that is
effective because
we need
we need some we need global governance
of some things because we have global
systems
so the fact that we haven't yet figured
out a way to not have it be corruptable
does not mean that the answer should be
or can be therefore we can have no
system
the the systems which need governing
exist
therefore they need governing
well and in fact you know that didn't
quite work but there are systems that
need governing that are global
and those systems aren't going anywhere
therefore we need to figure out a way to
govern them yeah we have to we have all
of the processes that need governing
have to be governed at a level that is
capable of managing them you know there
are some global processes i don't think
most of us who have seen the appalling
failure of government want to see
everything or even anything managed at
that level that doesn't have to be but
um but nonetheless we you know
we are stuck on a very tiny rock and
there are global processes and
externalities and they have to be
addressed uh you know in some sort of
adult form which is not taking place
but
at the moment we are uh we are in the
most
bizarre upside down world conceivable
and you know i'm even thinking as we're
talking here right i think the
conversation that you and i are now
having oddly a couple of rooms apart
is
what a normal conversation between
evolutionary biologists who are
long and i think happily
married
would have about their family's
well-being we know from what people say
to us that hearing our conversations is
keeping them sane and at the same moment
i think this very conversation where i
think frankly both you and i are um
at the end of our patients
with this insane nonsense
this conversation as healthy and
reasonable as it is as careful as it is
is actually probably a danger to our
channel right that in fact the very just
as our public health response is upside
down it is the very conversations you
most need to hear that are most likely
to be uh
mislabeled as disinformation and uh
thrown off of these platforms and i
don't know i i hope i hope people
will will
keep track of that hazard and i hope
people will also keep track of the fact
that we are
being very careful to point out it's not
like we're saying hey omicron is a uh a
an attenuated virus vaccine that uh just
so happens to be the kind you don't have
to drive anywhere to get because it'll
come find you right that's not what
we're saying and in fact there's there's
a there's a danger here that i can't
i can't rule out right just as
chickenpox comes back as shingles
we don't know what sarsko v2 does
decades later to people who've had it
i'm not eager to have had it but as
between the choice of facing the risk
that omicron might do something that we
don't know decades after one has had it
and the risk that these vaccines are
going to do something of that nature i
actually think you've got a better shot
with the with the virus and
who the hell are these
out of control
public health officials to tell me
otherwise they have not demonstrated
that they have deep knowledge of this in
fact they've demonstrated the opposite
[Music]